enjoy watching him on the worldwide
leader in sports long time
offensive lineman in the national
football league damian woody back here
on the rich eisen show how are you
damien
rich i'm good buddy how are you doing i
am doing well so uh let's
let's hit on on a couple of things here
uh you know that you are personally
familiar with
uh belichick how does he do it against
uh rookie quarterbacks so consistently
what what does he cook up what have you
seen with your own two
two eyes damien personally on this front
what
what well rich he's the he's the master
of illusion
um you know he just knows how to
scheme up coverages if you look at the
patriots defense
the best part of the defense is in the
back in their secondary and his ability
to disguise those coverages along with
being able to know how to break down
your protections and rush
and get after your quarterback and so
justin herbert has had a great year
probably going to maybe be the rookie of
the year
but he had never seen anything like a
bill belichick laid defense before
and what the what and what the patriots
did particularly on the defense side of
football was
they created just chaos russian you know
uh
running what they call stunts and uh all
different coverages
and when you're working quarterback you
have to look at all of that
it's a daunting task and pacers just
they just
completely overwhelmed the charges i
mean from
special teams i believe they had what
two
two two special teams touchdowns i i
believe
and they just completely dominated
uh the los angeles charges it was just a
coaching
it was a coaching clinic and i would
advise anyone just go
re-watch that game because if you want
to watch a coaching clinic watch bill
belichick in new england patriots so
again
i guess just uh because we we've had uh
brian billick on this show many times
and i ask him almost every time to
repeat the phrase that drives him crazy
that bill belichick will take away the
one thing that
that uh you need to win like the rest of
the coaches in the nfl
would never think of doing that right
that they're all dummies but it does
seem that bill
is able to do certainly against rookie
quarterbacks what other teams like
you know it's not like bruce aaron's and
todd bowles
don't know how to do it i mean and he
does it with
a different cast it's like just to say
do your job he doesn't just wave a wand
how does he do it
damien you know well i think i think the
difference is
is that a lot of coaches have their
system
and they're stubborn when it comes to
their system
coach belichick he's flexible he can
bring
anything at you at any time he can have
one minute he can have
four down linemen next step he might
next snap he might have one down lineman
and a bunch of linebackers and db's you
know he'll just throw out all these
different looks to confuse you
and that's what he does particularly
well with rookie quarterbacks because a
lot of times
they haven't seen these type of looks
that coach belichick would throw at him
and uh and that's why he's you know he's
had these rookie quarterbacks numbers
damien woody here uh on the rich eisen
show then why why isn't it uh i guess
you got to be belichick right because
another spot where you
um used to play detroit hires matt
patricia we saw bill o'brien get hired
in houston um the number of times joe
judges
and and brian flores appear to be
outliers here but they're also guys
that aren't offensive minded um or
patricia obviously defensive minded why
doesn't it work when belichick acolytes
go somewhere else
more often than not damien well i think
a lot of times we end up happening
richard
everyone tries to emulate coach
belichick so much
that they don't they let themselves go
in the process
and i remember having a conversation
with coach mangini um
after he was let go in in new york when
i was there with him with the jets
and one of the things that that that
came up was man i shouldn't
i should have i should have been myself
i should have you know had my own
personality and and not try to emulate
coach belichick
so much and i think that's what happens
a lot of times with
with a lot of these guys who come who
come from that
that tree is that
they want so bad to take everything from
new england
but they forget that they have to be
their own man in the process
and sometimes they can lose their own
way and i think that's where you got to
give guys like brian flores and joe judd
i think they're just they are who they
are they're going to be themselves yes
they
coached under coach belichick but
they're still going to be who they are
and i think players respect that that
aspect from them
yeah i think i saw one of the dolphins
players come off the field after there
was that bench clearer
uh against the the uh the bengals i
don't know who the player's name was but
the player went up
to uh brian flores who was probably
giving this player an earful about his
his demeanor during that skirmish and
flores
uh the player was given floor as a fist
pump and he refused to
fist bump back like you know kind of
reminding him i'm still the coach around
here
you know um it was a it was an
interesting moment although flores was
also out there on the field and you see
joe judge just crushing it right now
so at least one new york team is doing
it right damien
yeah yes you could you could you could
definitely say that rich
you could definitely say that at least
one new york team is doing it
joe judge he's brought up you know he's
brought a no-nonsense approach
very disciplined approach uh to the new
york football
giants and those got rich those guys are
playing hard as
hard as heck out there that's a ball
club that
regardless of what their record is
you're not going to want to play them at
this time of year because
they are who they are they're going to
punch you in the mouth
they certainly are are are playing very
well i got damian woody here
on the rich eisen show let's get to the
jets now
because you have been taking a similar
posture on twitter as i have
as well on the show and it's very
difficult you know
it's very difficult for me uh to keep
saying that a team
who i want to see succeed so well should
lose
um and uh they came awful close and i
guess greg williams needs to be invited
to the parade one day when trevor
lawrence is picking confetti out of his
beautiful hair
um but what what what is going on do you
think
with these players no one wants to lose
them all but what do you think is going
on with the jets right now
at this moment with this locker room
damien woody
well i would say there's an intense
amount amount of frustration
you know like you said we you know in
the media and i know fans talk about
it you know as far as the jets
quote-unquote tanking there's no
tanking when it comes to the locker room
there's no tank in when it comes to the
coaching staff
and there's no tanking when it comes to
the you know the like general manager
they want to win they understand that um
yeah they're the situation is not great
but they're trying to win
every they're trying to win every
meeting every practice every game
and unfortunately with with the jets you
have a situation where
it's kind of a perfect storm you have
years of bad drafting
which is left to cover you know pretty
bare
as far as depth and just elite talent
and then you've got a coaching situation
where it's just won the worst
international football league led by you
know
led by adam gates so
this situation is going to get resolved
there's only four games left they're
going to dismiss adam gates but you know
i've said before
richard and i think you would agree if
you look if you take a macro approach
and look at the jets
that's a pretty attractive job i think
joe douglas the gm has done a great job
of kind of restocking
the cover as far as draft picks cap
space and so
any any person any coach that's looking
at this situation
once the season is over they're going to
have their choice of a lot of good
coaches out there
well that's another reason why i want
them to lose as much as possible
um to be honest with you is because the
best
coaching candidates uh will not be
available to the jets
if they don't have the ability to choose
trevor lawrence i mean
to if you sit here and say you know hey
we got the third overall pick
uh but still come to a place that has
been so dysfunctional over the last few
years anyway
or you could say we've got trevor
lawrence we've got all these draft
choices it's the new york media market
let's go so who do you think would be
the best coach to bring in
to coach trevor lawrence if the jets do
actually complete the feat
over the next four weeks damian
which that's that's that's a tough
that's a that's an awful telephone
because there's a lot of there's a lot
of candidates out there i mean we've
heard you know
eric the enemy um
robert salah i don't know if i want to
mispronounce his name but
the defensive coordinator with the 49ers
um yeah salah the oc from the carolina
panthers his name is hot
you got we heard that you know we've
heard rumors now
this you know today about maybe bill
cower
i mean there's a lot of different uh
flavors of coaches that are going to be
available uh for the jets i tend to
believe rich
this team needs a ceo type of coach
they need a coach that's going to repair
the the
reputation of this franchise because
right now the new york jets are laughing
stop they're the butt of
every jokes around around the national
football league
they need a guy that's going to bring
credibility
that's going to instill culture that's
going to be able to work well with joe
douglas
um so you know for me i i
just i don't know if i want a hot
coordinator i need somebody who
who who's going to be that ceo guy
that can repair this rep that can repair
this reputation
well i mean uh bill cower would
obviously suffice over that front i mean
he's going to the pro football hall of
fame he's
he wins every week though on the set of
cbs you know what i mean like that's
that would be uh that that'd be again
the only reason why he would ever do
that is like here you go
you've got all of these draft choices
you don't have to move you live in new
york already and on top of it you get
trevor lawrence who wouldn't want to be
hooked up at the hip with trevor
lawrence i mean every single coach on
planet earth
who's interested in having a job with
all of the draft choices
and and again the number one media
market who wouldn't want that that's
that's why part of the reason why i want
the jets to keep doing this and i feel
for
sam darnold right i mean i totally feel
this kid totally deserves better than to
have this part of the conversation
involve him um and and you know
that that's why i i feel it's very
difficult to have this
this talk damien week and week out yeah
yeah listen i've been a sam donald fan
the whole time
um but i just feel like the time has
come where it's time to turn the page
i think that sam donna has been
beaten up and battered i think the just
organization has failed him
um he hasn't played well um anyone
any anyone watching it just can clearly
see um there's some
there's a lot of deficiencies in sam
donald's game but i also feel like he's
redeemable like he can be the things
that
ail him right now can be fixed in
another organization and under the right
tutelage
um so like i said i think i think he's
still a starter in this league
just not with the new york new york jets
before i let you go damien i saw your
tweet about how
the biggest signing this offseason may
have been the browns
signing bill callahan to be their
offensive line coach
uh using that as the door uh let's open
the conversation here on how real you
think the cleveland browns are at nine
and three
ah i i listen nine and three
bill park says would you know would
always say you are what your record says
you are they're
you know they're a good ball club i
still am skeptical about the cleveland
browns
um one of the stats that you know to me
one of the most important stats
is point differential and including
bronze i blink is like negative 15.
so yes they're not in three but
they they got a lot of work to do
i'm a big believer in their running game
i'm a big believer in
um defense particularly their their
front four
i'm still skeptical of baker mayfield
when it comes to playoff time
can he make those critical plays in
crunch time
to you know put your put your team over
the hump that's what i
that's what i need to see damon i
appreciate the time thanks for the two
cents
enjoy your work on espn let's uh let's
do this more often
thanks for the call absolutely thanks a
lot you got it i follow him on twitter
you should too at damian woody right
here on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here